the de-schooling society
is taking away from people
some of their major opportunities for
individual growth and social interaction
and even even general activism
i mean it's not just pure accident
that over the years student activism
has been one at typically at the
forefront
of many of the most important social
movements
partly it's just because young people
are a
period of their life when they're
relatively free
but it's also the fact that they're
together they can talk with one another
they can interact that's something
that's pretty much missing in
atomized capitalist society
then i'm running into a little bit of a
confusion here
on the one hand the history of
intellectuals and academia
sort of lines up with the status quo um
in the sense that we were talking about
nazism things before
but on the other hand they're on the
forefront of social change
how are these views compatible
their participants are in the forefront
of social change
uh the mainstream may be
status quo and conservative which it is
take a look at student activism
it's usually opposed by the
administration and most of the faculty
but nevertheless it takes place because
this is a relatively
free institution which means that there
are
opportunities to break out of the
uh doctrinaire
system of attempted orientation you know
we're not living in
uh totalitarian dictatorships where if
you say the wrong thing you get sent to
the
to the concentration camp we're living
in societies with a
relative degree of freedom uh
often uh infringed by authoritarian
structures but they don't
have the kind of force they do if the ss
troops are standing
behind you we shouldn't compare
ourselves with that